Excellent work! You've just completed your first tough question
on filling out the charts for parsing.
Because parsing is everywhere in the computing world--
from HTML to E-mail,
to languages like JavaScript or Python
or C and C++--
this notion of memoizing--
writing down intermediate results so that we can refer to them--
is critical to performance; and because parsing happens all the time,
this performance really matters.
Now these are some of the first questions
to really stretch our ability to do abstract reasoning,
so don't worry if it's taken you a few more trials on these exercises
than it may have in the past.
On the other hand, we should definitely be excited
about the goal that we're working towards.
Very soon, we're going to have a complete parser
for HTML and JavaScript.